Here's everything that happened in Korea today in case you missed it.
So the election was yesterday
and the ruling party faced a crushing defeat
which put a lot of pressure on the current president.
So how bad was this defeat?
The Democratic Party of Korea,
they won 175 seats and the current party that was in power,
they only won 108 seats. More about the election,
the voter turnout hit a 32 year high at 67%.
People went out this year two give the vote.
And in other news,
the foreign population in Korea is expected to reach 7%
in the year 2042. This doesn't seem like a lot,
but this would actually be about double the current rate
in which we have now in Korea.
And in 2042 is expected
that 10% of the workforce in Korea will be foreign workers.
What did you think about the news today?
Let me know in the comments.